people who have power start to  become blind to the breaks they got  the sources the opportunities that came  their way  by where they were born or um  the just by fate and they start to  develop a sense that it takes special  people to lead  right uh and and it is this sense of  like  wow i i have power there there must be  we justify it we think wow i'm some sort  of  uniquely gifted person to rise to the  top  and why is that perilous because number  one it leads to  and we've done work on this um certain  kinds of ideas about compensation well  maybe i deserve  20 million dollars a year for the work i  do right it's like a veil of meritocracy  in a sense  it is very much so very much so uh and  and the idea of meritocracy right that  it's really the special people that  you know that get into the special  schools or deserve certain kinds of  compensation or  get treated by the law differently